climbing the world's highest mountain a
feat achieved by more than 6 000 people
since two men became the first 70 years
ago
Edmund Hillary and Sherpa Tenzing norgy
made history on 29 May 1953 when they
stood on the summit of Everest
now these climbers have gathered in
Tamil in downtown Kathmandu to pay
tribute
has climbed nine of the world's highest
peaks including Everest after 1953 when
saw Edmund Hillary climbed the mount air
base and he started building the school
and we got the education so we
definitely recall like the southern lady
like
the light of our life so there are so
many impacts a good impact to us
[Music]
as Nepal celebrates the Platinum Jubilee
of the first Ascent of Everest
Mountaineers are campaigning to draw
attention to how difficult that's become
because of global warming
former British Army soldier Hari
buramagar became the first double
amputee to climb Everest in may he says
the mountain has changed it would be
very very important not just mountainous
but uh scientist explorers and whoever
are working in climate change but also
who are experiencing about the climate
change
ever since Tenzing Norge Sherpa and
Edmund Hillary climbed Everest there's
been an exponential growth in
mountaineering and tourism in Nepal it's
an important source of revenue for the
government and income for local
communities now there's growing concern
that climate change will impact the
industry and the people rely on it
changing studies how increasing
temperatures impact snowfall and glacial
melt in the Hindu Kush himalay much of
the water in the world is stored in the
form of glaciers and so once this ice
resource starts to deplete away the
amount of water that's available in the
near future will be steadily decrease
and there are one maybe more than nearly
2 billion people that depend on the Melt
water from these resources
people living in the mountain are
especially vulnerable melting glaciers
trigger flash floods affecting their
communities Downstream at other times
there's not enough rain those who rely
on Everest for their livelihoods and
survival say climate change is
threatening both ramyata limbu Al
Jazeera Kathmandu